in what mindset could you start the game
uh do you think actually it favors white
or black this armageddon system i think
it's fairly equal maybe slightly
favorable for black i feel like it's
psychologically a little bit easier to
play black at least that's what i feel
it didn't seem like today
[Laughter]
in principle right in principle yeah
like i mean today i didn't have much of
a time advantage but yeah the position
was so good
yeah it didn't didn't matter uh it's
interesting i had this in
in the in the champions chester event
against duda recently and
queen e2 uh yeah i went went for the
same thing and he went for knight d7
which is a little bit inaccurate because
i can take on d5
um
but
yeah a4
uh a4 is interesting but still if he
doesn't achieve anything he's just
helping me to push everything i thought
already you're going to be playing
immediately bishop h3 and knight d2
um
yeah i didn't think about bishop h3 uh
if i thought about it i might might have
done it okay so rook c1 and what is the
turning point for uh here for white you
just started to play so powerfully b46
yeah queen b6 was strange that was a
strange i thought he would play c5
so i feel like i've been tricked this
exact way before
uh and then yeah just everything kind of
yeah because actually with when you
wasted one yeah
one temple so i think i've been tricked
like this before in some game and then
some training blitz game right yeah or
something and then just everything in
this place and do you think after queen
b6 b4 there is already a clear advantage
for white i think at least
a small but clearer than that yeah sure
yeah because after that uh now
i mean unless you can solve this
yeah here whether e5 is possible yeah
i take it
with what a knight
i think with the knights
yeah 95
and
and after this bishop e4 bishop b4
d4 d5
r8
b5 maybe
you don't care yeah
it does not look good for black
yeah
yeah but after this it was also kind of
hopeless yeah i mean the question was
whether he could take on take on d4
bishop d4 yeah
95.
lines are
yeah with 95
oh
95 maybe
oh maybe this is the way
and
[Music]
if i move the bishop then he can take
and play knight cc oh he might take a
knight c6 i don't know if it works
probably take the queen
with the bishop
or bishop b5 you go
oh yeah
and bishop d5 oh that's very strong so
he cannot take him but if you cannot
take on b5 then he has to allow
94 there may maybe have some chances to
hold
or we should be two
of them i thought cb5
in knight c6 yeah
but it goes to show here has to play
very very
concretely and okay i mean e4
uh
i mean if it doesn't take on c5 it's
just complete collapse yeah
but here yeah this doesn't doesn't work
what did you have in your head uh i have
okay i had a couple of thoughts yeah um
first of all
i wanted to win
um 100 sure yeah no i told you this you
see i said you don't want to give even a
one percent chance that he can
kick back
and
also i thought
it would be nice to torture him
what a cruel guy
[Laughter]
anything you can you can gain before
before before the match
i i was um i i saw already that i had
this idea with g4 h4 to break his
structure up so i was not worried at all
that there would be a draw in this yeah
well it was a great victory and it was
nice to see that in the previous round
you had some shaky earthquake things
going on around your games right